now tension is building in the town of
zwecham in Northern Kosovo where ethnic
serbs have gathered outside the city
hall this morning which is being guarded
by kosovan police now the serbs are
angry about the election of ethnic
Albanian Mayors on Friday there were
violent confrontations when
demonstrators block the officials from
entering their offices let's go to
assadbag he's outside the municipal
building in zwechan in Northern Kosovo
he joins us on the phone so I said
tension's Brewing already this morning
between ethnic serbs and government
officials talk us through exactly what's
happening there
so there's a considerable crowd here
outside the municipality building now
what happened earlier was that there was
a sizable police presence also major
forces are there so NATO forces had a
line and the protesters were in front of
them and then uh what happened is they
just walked straight past and made their
way to the municipality building now
they've tried to enter please push them
back and then use gas to leave CF gas to
disperse them the crowd in fact in the
municipality building and now there's a
police line as well as NATO forces there
now NATO the United States the United
Kingdom and other countries have asked
Kosovo to de-escalate the situation
they're pretty much blaming Kosovo but
because when authorities are saying well
they have a right to uphold the
Constitution
who make up the majority in the country
but not the majority of these areas were
elected even though the majority of
serbs boycotted that election so the
turnout was just under three and a half
percent some of you've made elected with
fewer than 200 votes
the reality on the ground is that many
of the serbs are outside here now have
been chanting served yet they don't
recognize kosovo's Independence they
don't recognizes institutions they're
withdrawn from the institutions and they
believe Kosovo should be a part of
Serbia not just these northern areas
they don't pay taxes in Kosovo they
don't even pay the electricity company
here and that's the tension that ongoing
and yes the international uh other
International partners of Kosovo are
asking the country to de-escalate but
the people standing here don't want to
move they don't believe you've made the
legitimate and they don't want them to
take office
okay I said we're going to leave it
there but uh you will be keeping an eye
on the situation for us asset beg
speaking outside the municipal building
in zvechan where a number of protesters
have gathered in Northern Kosovo